I certainly wouldn't claim that atheists
have no meaning in their lives because
that would obviously be false lots of
things can be meaningful to people in
various ways the real difference between
theism and Atheism when it comes to
meaning is the kinds and degrees of
meaning available to us so by way of
analogy if you're a vegan it's not that
you have no food it's that the range of
foods available to you is is much
narrower than the range of foods
available to someone who isn't a vegan
there are fewer options for you
similarly if you're an atheist you might
find meaning in what you do but the
kinds of meaning available to you are
significantly reduced I would argue that
your varieties of meaning are almost
completely limited to the realm of the
subjective mainly your feelings hence
atheism is the veganism of worldviews if
you'd like a mouthwatering riye steak
figuratively speaking you need to go
somewhere other than the veganism of
World Views fortunately Pierce Morgan
just did an awesome interview with the
Christian Scientist and philosopher
Steven Meyer they spent most of the
interview discussing scientific evidence
for what Dr Meyer calls the god
hypothesis later in the interview Pierce
had some questions about why an all
powerful Creator would allow so much
suffering in our world this is the
infamous problem of evil but at the very
end Pierce had one final question final
question what's the meaning of life
ending with an easy one I see well I
think It ultimately is um to come into a
relationship with the Creator who made
the universe easy question easy answer
in the closing chapter of my book I talk
about uh Victor Frankle and the man's
search for meaning and how Universal
that is and that nothing can mean
anything to a rock or to an atom or to a
planet things only mean things to
persons so if there is to be meaning in
life there must be genuine persons who
to whom we can mean something and and U
and who can mean something to us
interesting point to even have the
possibility of meaning there must be
persons nothing is Meaningful to a rock
but watch this and yet we all die and so
I think if there is a God reopens that
question of ultimate meaning the French
existentialists used to say SRA without
an infinite reference point nothing
finite has any lasting or enduring
meaning right for there to be meaning
there must be persons but human persons
are all going to die eventually we'll
all be dead so if we're the only persons
meaning will eventually die with us
without an infinite reference point
there's no lasting
meaning but if there is an infinite
reference point and that infinite
reference point is personal that is to
say if the universe was created by a
personal agent who wants to know us then
the then the possibility of enduring
meaning is again on the table think
about something that was meaningful to
you at some point earlier in your life
that just isn't meaningful to you
anymore I'll give you some examples I
grew up in several different places
mostly a trailer par in West Virginia
back then after school we would build
forts in the woods or shoot things with
bows or rifles or play video games first
on the Atari 2600 which most of you are
too young to have even heard of and
eventually on the original Nintendo
which was also before your time and
these things were incredibly meaningful
to us when we were kids I defeated Mike
Tyson one of the greatest boxers in
history numerous times on the video game
Mike Tyson's punch out
it's quite an accomplishment to defeat
the heavyweight champion of the world in
his prime take that Jake
Paul I once won an archery competition I
remember being mad after the competition
because they didn't give out any awards
it was just you won congratulations he
won everyone not even a ribbon I thought
I should have gotten a ribbon for doing
something as meaningful as winning an
archery contest
one year my friends and I built a six
story Fort then some other kids came
along when we weren't there and tore it
down we later found one of those kids he
was dumb enough to walk through our
trailer park after tearing down our Fort
let's just say he got punched in the
face repeatedly and when he ran he
dropped his backpack and we threw his
books all over the trailer park why he
destroyed our Fort we spent weeks
building that thing
now I look back at all of that and think
who cares about winning a video game who
cares about winning an archery
competition I don't remember ever
shooting a bow again after that who
cares about the fort not me or any of us
who built it so absolutely no one these
things that were so meaningful to us
when we were kids things that we were
willing to fight over just aren't as
meaningful as we once thought
eventually everyone who is involved in
any of those situations will be dead
there won't even be the memory of those
things happening so whatever meaning
there was it was limited it was
temporary the question is is all meaning
like that is all meaning going to fade
away well if there's an infinite
reference point if that infinite
reference point is personal then there's
the possibility of lasting meaning yeah
I mean if you I've had this conversation
with Ricky jaas it's like well if
everything if you only believe that what
happens in your existence here is that's
it how sort of pointless transitory and
vacuous it must all be to you whereas if
you believe in the concept of of in
infinite life or bit in a different way
that's great am I the only one who
thought that Pierce Morgan was about to
do a Ricky jves impression I don't know
why I thought that I've never seen
Pierce do an impression of anyone but if
he had done an impression of Ricky Jes
and the impression was absolutely
hilarious would it have been ultimately
pointless according to Ricky yes
according to pierce no that's the
question that haunted me as a teenager
you I was yeah it was what's it going to
matter in 100 years no matter what I
worked on no matter what I achieved no
matter what goal I I set I I thought I
couldn't what what was the point I
thought the exact same thing when I was
a teenager but the realization affected
me completely differently from the way
it affected Steven Meyer I one time came
across the quote from Bertrand Russell
where he talks about all the all the
great labors of of the human race and
the the noay the the brightness of human
uh achievement Noonday human achievement
well is destined for extinction in the
vast death of the solar system I wasn't
much fun at parties as so teenaged
Steven Meyer found it depressing to
think that everything he ever did would
ultimately be
meaningless teenaged David wood found it
exhilarating teenaged David wood thought
to himself yes everything I do is
meaningless but everything that everyone
else can do to me is also meaningless so
I might as well do whatever I want and
who cares what the rest of you do in
response at a certain point in life
whether it's when you're very young or
often when you're nearing the end those
sorts of questions perally I think when
you get near the end yeah when you're
really questioning am I right is this
young people ask what the point is
because they're looking forward what's
the point of everything I'm about to do
in life old people ask what the point is
because they're Looking Backward what
was the point of everything I just did
in life and looking forward is there
something still to come it just seems to
me completely in the same way that when
atheists can't explain what happened
before the Big Bang uh and when they
can't say that when they say nothing
happens when you die and stuff that's
where my belief in God gets in massively
increased here Pierce is just pointing
out that atheists have trouble offering
satisfying answers to some of the big
questions yes they do it's one of the
main reasons I think it must there must
be a God is that actually none of that
would make sense that we just started
one day and there was this weird thing
called Nothing before there which no one
can really explain to me what that is
and at the end of it it just ends and
then that's the end of that Pierce is
making a good point here if there's only
meaning when there are persons and if
persons are this C mic accident this
temporary blip of meaning in a sea of
meaninglessness then there's no meaning
followed by meaning suddenly popping
into existence followed by a return to
meaninglessness for all
eternity but if there's an infinite
reference point then there's always been
meaning and there always will be
meaning so meaning isn't an anomaly it's
an eternal part of
reality that doesn't make any sense that
someone would create something so
extraordinary that's led to us the human
being and then at the end that's it well
that is not bad Pierce you figured out a
huge
issue now you just need to figure out
how to keep your guests from screaming
over each other when you host
debates hint your Tech guys have the
ability to cut people's mics that's the
other thing about the grief emotion is
that it it seems to be telling us
there's something profoundly unnatural
not intend Ed by death someone dies and
you experience
grief what's the point of the
grief it's as if there's a part of you
crying out that something isn't the way
it's supposed to be to me when I look
inside the cell and see the evidence of
that digital storage transmission and
processing system Richard Dawkins
himself said was on seeing an animation
of this recently that he was knocked
sideways with Wonder at the the
intricacy and complexity of the digital
information processing that's going on
inside sales sadly Richard Dawkins has
admitted that nothing could even
possibly convince him that God exists he
admitted that even if he heard an
audible voice speaking to him even if he
saw a message written out to him in the
Stars he still wouldn't
believe that's Faith this is
extraordinary it's like it's like a a a
3D printer youve got digital code
directing the construction of
three-dimensional structures and
machines all inside the tiniest recesses
of the cell there is no materialistic
chemical evolutionary or other account
of that your DNA is a set of
instructions for building you and the
cells of your body are filled with tiny
machines that read the set of
instructions translate the instructions
and build the necessary
structures what does this all point to
we see features inside the cell that are
reminiscent of our own high-tech
information and digital technology this
seems to be pointing obviously to a
Transcendent mind fun discussion putting
it all together human beings have this
quest for meaning but lasting meaning
requires an infinite reference point
science points to this infinite
reference point and so one of the
greatest human desires ultimate meaning
lines up perfect
with one of the greatest human Endeavors
scientific
investigation I don't recall ever
believing in God when I was little I
think I was around 13 years old when I
officially realized that I was an
atheist I was probably around 14 or 15
when I concluded that I only believed
certain things were right or wrong
because I'd been programmed by
society and I must have been around 16
or 17 when I concluded that everything
is ultimately me meaningless I noticed
that most other people found what they
did meaningful I regarded their belief
in meaning as a kind of delusion crutch
to help them get through life as I said
as far as I was concerned we might as
well do whatever we feel like doing with
the little bit of time we've got so
that's what I did and I ended up in
couple of jails couple of Mental
Hospitals a few
prisons going to jail fail would bother
most people and on a superficial level I
didn't want to be locked up but on a
deeper level I just didn't care what's
the difference between on the one hand
going to school spending 40 years
working and then retiring shriveling up
and waiting to die and on the other hand
doing whatever you feel like doing
crushing anyone who gets in your way and
spending life prisons and Mental
Hospitals who
cares better to burn out than to fade
away I was in jail when I met a
Christian the first Christian I ever met
who put up a fight when I started
arguing with him he made me so mad that
I began studying Christianity to show
him that he was wrong along the way I
figured out some of what Steven Meyer
talked about in his interview with
Pierce Morgan the EV evidence of design
in nature caused me to doubt my atheism
I also studied the resurrection of Jesus
and before that I had no clue that all
of the core claims surrounding the
resurrection are grounded in history all
the evidence we have tells us that Jesus
died by crucifixion all the evidence we
have tells us that he was alive again
later that looked like it might be a
miracle and combined with some of the
other things I was studying it may made
me think that I should at least say a
prayer and when I sat up from that
prayer the entire world looked different
everything was instantly infused with
meaning I still had to spend several
years in prison but it was the best time
of my life up until then I knew God I
knew the one who created the
universe I was connected to the infinite
reference point
care to join me
[Music]